muy buenos días desde la Corte Penal de
Manhattan aquí de momento se mantiene
todo muy tranquilo pero si estos últimos
días habíamos visto máxima seguridad
ahora incluso es el doble Se esperan
como decías que mañana haya protestas
manifestaciones muchos curiosos que se
acerquen tanto a la famosa Torre Trump
donde se espera que el expresidente
duerma esta noche como aquí a la Corte
Penal de Manhattan a donde acudirá
mañana a entregarse de manera voluntaria
para la lectura de esos 30 cargos hoy y
mañana todos los agentes de las fuerzas
del orden están bajo alerta por lo que
pueda pasar no solamente para la
seguridad del expresidente en su
desplazamiento hasta aquí sino también
para esas protestas y manifestaciones
que se puedan dar de hecho ya hay una
organizada para mañana a las 12 del
mediodía y el alcalde de la ciudad
dedica Adams que hoy ha ofrecido una
rueda de prensa ya ha dicho que la
ciudad está más que preparada para lo
que pueda pasar y ha advertido a los
seguidores de Trump que se controlen aún
así estamos viendo muchas vallas
metálicas tanto en la torre Trump como
aquí en la Corte Penal para proteger por
lo que pueda ocurrir mañana
en unas horas el expresidente Trump
llegará hasta Nueva York que sigue en el
proceso legal contra él que vamos a ver
Si eso no es nada fácil de explicar
porque puede ir cambiando a medida que
avancen las horas por qué Pues porque
aquí tanto la ciudad de Nueva York como
el propio sistema legal del país se
mueve en un terreno completamente
desconocido ya que es la primera vez que
un expresidente se enfrenta a este tipo
de situación pero en principio lo que
sabemos que va a ocurrir o lo que
debería ocurrir en un caso normal es que
mañana el expresidente vendrá aquí a la
Corte Penal está previsto la hora las
dos y cuarto de la tarde hora local
Entonces se le tomarán las huellas
dactilares no estás seguro si se le hará
esa foto policial o no Porque muchos
acusados Parece ser que prefieren que no
se les haga porque les resulta
humillante y además el equipo de Donald
Trump ha dicho que puede llegar a
filtrarse a la prensa Así que esa es una
de las cosas que no está confirmada
luego se espera también que se le haga
esa lectura de cargos y que él mismo de
su versión está previsto que lo niegue
todo y que se muestre o sea se defina
como inocente algo que lleva haciendo
desde el principio todo ocurrirá en el
piso número 15 del edificio de la Corte
Penal en la sala a la que está al frente
el juez Juan merchal que es el que lleva
este caso contra Donald Trump